herzlich willkommen zu tun a half men
cooles gartenliege gemacht ob das video
cool ist können uns in die kommentare
schreiben
und da bin i und alex und alex und ich
wir haben dieses geniale hoch weg gebaut
und zwar kann es sein dass ihr zwei
produktplatzierung macht ja darf ich
werde mir jetzt gerade von prefa
zuschauern hätte dem griechischen t
shirt in eine nummer größer schicken
können wenn er sie gerade aus dem
presswurst vielleicht wäre vielleicht
besser gewesen aber wir waren richtig
cooles hochbeet gebaut passend zum stil
von unserem haus mit dingen die wir nach
dem bau übrig hatten und zwar aus einem
treffer fassade und natürlich hier mit
fichte und dieses hoch bei sibirische
lärche wollte gerade sagen ich habe noch
nicht angeschaut war falsche sibirische
lärche es ehrlich jetzt wahnsinn
warum wir sibirische lärche genommen
haben ganz klar ist langsam gewachsen
ist holz alex und sehr
witterungsbeständig oder wollten
ich habe das bei google gelesen also auf
jede waren wir richtig gut gemacht ich
wusste vorher nicht dass meine frau hier
nur zierpflanzen reinmacht ein hochbeet
nehmen normalerweise für kräuter kräuter
nutzpflanzen aber meine frau hat hier
einen zierpflanzen genommen ganz einfach
weil wir hier immer abends sitzen was
ein tee trinken was essen oder sie ist
einfach cool aus wie man aus dem fenster
schaut sieht man so richtig cool
diese pflanzen hier extra für die bienen
für die bienen ist es sehr sehr wichtig
die ganzen blüten die ganzen pflanzen
und deswegen haben das gemacht da
überrascht es im juni weil du hast
irgendwann 16 jahren auf jeden fall
richtig cooles bild was wir gemacht
haben
ich würde auch wirklich sagen luxus beet
oder muss man eher ganz ganz ehrlich
sagen also wahnsinn
man kann schon hochbeeten sich auch
fertig kaufen im baumarkt um die 100 200
euro nicht in der größe natürlich dann
rechnet mit acht euro richtig ja auf
jeden fall aber wir sind natürlich
masochistisch veranlagt und wollen das
ding übrigens selber bauen bitte fragt
eure eltern nicht was mal so riss muss
heißt weil so eine stufe diesen kann
ahlen nicht mehr betreten macht es nicht
die vorteile eines hoch gleich ganz ganz
einfach der erste tag herr alex ja der
vorteil ist dass das sich die die erde
schneller aufwand und dadurch die firma
wächst genau
ein anderer vorteil ist dass man
eigentlich nicht gehen muss weil sie das
ding selber denkt
womit sie war ja kommt bestimmt
vielleicht genau und zwar ist es
wirklich so viele haben zum beispiel
angst hast da schnecken reinkommen und
zwar bei uns wird es dann so aussehen
die strecke wird dann hoch man
wahrscheinlich wird plötzlich sehen aha
da ist ein geist gar kein salat drin
sind zierpflanzen so ein mist ich muss
wieder runter habe ich recht genau geht
es darüber auf die andere seite will
daheim und hochriegl das ist möglich da
ist es salatbuffet und hier nicht um das
mit den schnecken zu verhindern gibt es
ganz einfachen trick alex kennst du denn
da muss ich sie nicht ehrlich wenn es
daheim selber und hochbeet habt dann
müsst ihr einen kupferdraht drum herum
machen oder eine kupfer leiste und das
mögen die schnecken gar nicht dann
kommen die schnecken schon mal gar nicht
hoch es ist gewusst hat sich der
rhythmus ist jetzt weist darauf hin es
hilft wenn wir nicht so auf jeden fall
dann ist doch was anderes und zwar
ungeziefer gibt es da zum beispiel auch
ratten oder mäuse haben wir nicht ratten
haben wir hier hatten zum beispiel mäuse
können wir uns auch nicht reinkommen
alex warum weil die müssten sich durch
den beton fressen habe ich recht genau
und das machen raten nichts zu fressen
habe ich recht auf jeden fall genau da
also wie gesagt und dann ist andere ist
natürlich auch ergonomisch man arbeitet
auf arbeitshöhe man muss ständig bücken
genau man kann hier alles pflanzen rufen
machen möchte dann muss ich mal bitten
und ein komma nix warum müssen sich
durch die einbindung presse
ein ganz ganz geniales ding das ist das
erste hochbeet das ich machen uns war es
schon mischen das zehnte alex du hast
auch bequem daheim ja ich habe mal ein
großes genau hast auch ein hochbeet
dabei aber wenn wir noch sarah übrig
haben
das ok auf jeden fall haben das ding
gemacht wirklich aus komplett baustoffen
die wir vom bau übrig haben weil wir zu
viel bestellt haben okay wenn wir
stellen das material nicht immer
ich kann mir vorkommt es gemacht haben
das gesagt
genau dieses mal haben wir nach hause
oma hat uns richtig spaß gemacht dieses
hoch bild zu machen später kommt
natürlich auf die sally unter christian
die werde es daher pflanzen der
christian gestern schon da hat das hoch
bremer angeschaut und der christian ist
garten und landschaftsbauer und er hat
gesagt er hat in seinem leben noch nie
so ein geniales hochbett gesehen wenn es
nicht so komisch aussieht sondern
richtig designmäßig also mich der
wahnsinn als schauriges hochbeet an
guckt euch das video an und schreibt uns
was in die kommentare hier könnten gar
alex und mir nette sachen schreiben und
die anderen sachen können den wind
schreiben wäre das in ordnung also aber
nein ich auch oft nicht vor der kamera
ok alles klar sagen wir wieder an so man
kann natürlich ein hochbeet auf
verschiedene arten mit verschiedenen
materialien bauen unser altes hoch weder
gibt es sogar noch ein video das war aus
aluminium
nur haben wir hier eine ziemlich langes
hochbeet und da mehr aluminium richtig
also viel zu teuer gewesen und wir haben
uns jetzt geholfen entschieden waren
schon öfters holzhof wenig gebaut auch
bei ihrem garten genau dann nachteil bei
holz sich natürlich dass es schnell
vermutet und oftmals wird ein holz
hochbeet einfach auf den boden gestellt
und zieht immer ein wasser und nach drei
vier fünf jahren vermutet dass holz und
da muss man neues machen
um dies zu umgehen haben uns überlegt
wir bauen hier eine unterkonstruktion
und haben hier schon rasen kantensteine
rein gemacht und auf die rasenkante und
steine
wir haben jetzt im alexa green zusammen
eine holzkonstruktion bauen
und nachdem er die holzkonstruktion
gebaut haben werden wir die seiten mit
prima verkleiden richtig alles genau so
genau
also ist immer cool und coolen
untergrund hat wo das wasser ab sondern
kann das wirklich eure holzkonstruktion
ich im wasser steht und wir treiben
spitze deswegen haben wir hier ein rasen
kantensteine reingelegt einbetoniert und
jetzt haben wir diese bauten
schutzmatten und diese bauten
schutzmatten werden mir jetzt hier
außenrum legen und später unsere
holzkonstruktion drauf bauen können
welche stauf was sagen wenn du nicht
sagst du fällst niemand auf dass du
nicht genau
und dann werden schrauben zusammen mit
elemente zusammen ja und dann quasi wie
im hausbau die tafel zusammen stimme die
ecken zusammen fixieren
er habe schrauben und dann ist das schon
okay und wie das gemacht wird das zeigen
uns jetzt der alex und ich was machst du
[Musik]
wir haben es natürlich immer alles
zusammen die pläne schon im vornherein
gemacht haben uns das holz zugeschnitten
und wir verwenden ihren ganz normal als
fichten tannen holz ganz einfach weil es
einfach am günstigsten mal richtig alex
genau war einfach am günstigsten und
deswegen haben wir das fichtenholz
wichtig ist beim bau als hochbeet ist
dass man sich wirklich mühe macht am
anfang plan erstellt alle einzelteile
zusammen sagt man kann es auch im
baumarkt zusammenlegen lassen wenn man
keine säge zu hause hat und und dann
macht es ein baulich sehr viel spaß wie
geht auch relativ schnell habe ich recht
alex genau
[Musik]
so blöd wie ich gerade vor schwierig die
wurde
[Musik]
mit dem ich schon abenteuer in brettnähe
durchzusägen lässig mit dem schon ein
abenteuer kanadische autor alex warum
von unterbinden wenn man schon dabei
sind als fachmann unter uns warum von
unten wie gesagt wahnsinn nicht merken
verzichtet nach außer hat gesehen dass
ich mache das wie ein roboter
[Musik]
weißt du warum der türkische flughafen
in vier jahren fertig war und der
deutsche konnte warum warum sie
zusätzliches ambuja waren lauter
deutsche firma mit know how in berlin ja
glaube dass so zu trübe wie du hier
bereiten jetzt gerade ganze konstruktion
vor ganz ganz wichtig dass wir hier aufs
maßgenau arbeit haben dann haben wir
nachher das problem nicht wenn wir die
fassadenteile hin schrauben richtig alex
ja was wirst du sagen jetzt haben wir
unsere konstruktion zusammengenagelt und
jetzt wenn man sie als zusammenführen
und eigenes gerippe von unserem hochbeet
bauen was auch ganz ganz wichtig beim
hochbeet wir hatten es ja vorher schon
der nachteil eines hochbeet es ist
natürlich das minus mehr bewässern muss
als normales bett weil ganze weil das
wasser einfach unten raus läuft und
deswegen haben wir hier mit gardena
zusammen haben wir hier ein
bewässerungssystem gebaut und dieses
bewässerungssystem ist unterirdisch und
das haben wir dann als wir den rasen
gelegt haben komplett gelegt und mit dem
bewusstsein dass wir schon hochbeet
bauen werden das heißt dieses
bewässerungssystem wird nachher im beet
mit drin sein und einen sensor wird dann
messen wenn zu wenn es zu trocken ist
und das wird dann automatisch bewässert
und dieses diese konstellation diese
verwirrung wie gesagt um nachher noch
hoch legen jetzt und dann den pflanzen
entlang zusammenstecken mordes jungs
tropf leitung stimmt tropf leitung nicht
sagen auf jeden fall wir stecken jetzt
alles zusammen und schauen wie es
aussieht alex oder ob mir richtig
gemessen haben sehen wir jetzt fangen
wir gerade nicht wir fangen gerade mit
diesem brett wir haben da noch ein gebot
für die tropf leitung pop leitung heißt
das album habe ich ja selbst das knie
weil wenn du lebst dann kann nichts
falsch machen und nichts kaputt machen
und jetzt machen die verbindungsstücke
rein dass man die stabilität rein
kriegen und geschraubt gleich an
also normal macht man ein hochbeet
wirklich beim auf eine arbeitshöhe wie
bei der kirche zum beispiel dass du bei
85 90 cm mich meine frau mich einfach
riesig und verbaut haben deswegen müsst
ihr ein bisschen weiter runter gehen
das heißt wir werden später sich auf 70
zentimeter landen da käme auch schön in
den garten reinschauen und was wir jetzt
auch nicht gedacht haben dass man
kleinen durchgang machen aber das ist
noch zwei bett zusammen schrauben müssen
ist kein problem und hat so jetzt können
jetzt einfach hier absägen macht sie weg
alex immer schön waagrecht halter genau
richtig ansätze wie ein heißes messer
durch die butter
[Musik]
ja frau schwer gemacht was soll ich
zeige dass es sehen rasches sehen so
jetzt haben wir bewiesen warum wir mit
dem flughafen fällig geworden sind wir
haben nicht die kreissägen gesucht haben
[Musik]
ganz wichtig bitte solche dinge zu hause
nicht nachmachen dafür brauchen wir dich
übung kraft talent und die wir das
andere achtung talent ja talent kenntnis
kinder natürlich nicht ist ruhig seine
musik konzentrieren
[Musik]
warum fragt ihn ein
so jetzt hab ich gesehen wir haben noch
ein paar sachen ändern müssen dank
günther und jetzt haben wir hier noch
ein kleinen weg gemacht da wären wir
noch nachher mit beton zu schützen und
gleich noch ein paar platten darüber
legen oder alex ja
[Musik]
wenn ihr mal das video angeschaut hat
wie man die prüfer fassade herangemacht
haben machen wir genau das gleiche
ich möchte das holz einfach schützen vor
irgendwelchen schwitzwasser
kondenswasser und deswegen machen wir
diese ewigen bahn hin
das ist du hast mich entwickeln ist noch
nicht 80 prozent kautschuk 80 40 sind
120 liter kommt auf jeden fall machen
wir das hin als schutz ganz einfach ihr
seht wenn wir etwas machen dann will ich
zu 100 prozent
deswegen bin ich da unter alex damit ihr
kein pfusch am bau ist sieht man ja an
diesem herrin der grünen jacke
das hört sich zwar weiter die
holzkonstruktion werden jetzt noch
kunden an den rand steigen befestigen
wenn man einfach nur ein paar winkel und
werden ich finde jetzt einfach an bord
[Musik]
wir arbeiten mit allen tricks und waren
hier nicht seine gewindestangen um die
konstruktion an einstein festzumachen
baden schraube ja ich kenne auch in die
maden schraube ja auf jeden fall und um
die richtig pech zu bekommen zwei
komponenten kleber und da braucht man ja
beide komponenten damit es den klebt
habe ich recht ja es ist wieder ändern
ja die zwei komponente muss ich halt
vermischen ja meine eltern haben sich
auch nicht ja und was ist raus kommen
alex ist rausgesprungen zehn kameras
machen ich muss mich ganz kurz jemand
macht macht
[Musik]
wie heißt die brücke in istanbul die
krause es gibt drei aber die post pro
jahr genau was ist mit der bibel du
früher als üblich und standard ist oder
die schalung für das hofbräu haben jetzt
aufgebaut und jetzt komme ich zu der
fitzel arbeit und diese fitzel arbeit
damit meine ich gerade diese folie
wir möchten ja auch dieses holz innen
drin schützen das ist nicht verrottet
und deswegen machen wir hier eine
teichfolie rein aber dann müsste ganz
ganz arg aufpassen folgendes wenn ihr
wir machen jetzt diese epdm bahn rein
das ist auch nicht wohl aber eine sehr
hochwertige und wir hatten das auch noch
übrig als den teich gebaut haben das
heißt das ganz hoch wie das mir pausen
eigentlich aus teilen die mir noch übrig
hatten vom bau und das ist eine epdm
bahn
das hat keine weichmacher drin wenn ihr
eine normale folie reinmachen der
normale teichfolie reinmacht hat die
meistens wirklich weichmacher drin ist
nicht gut für pflanzen vor gemüse
da gebe ich einen coolen tipp und ist
auch richtig günstig am besten im diesem
noppenfolie da gibt es wenig zu den
noppen bau folie
da geht man baumarkt mal nach wieso
braun und da kommt vielleicht ein
quadratmeter drei euro und bei der
polizist schon bei 20 bei dieser epdm
was keine weichmacher hat wirst du bis
zum noch teurer
deswegen ganz ganz wichtig überlegt euch
gut als nicht reinmacht habe ich recht
alex richtig genau dann ist das einfach
hier festnageln im grünen zusammen die
tun jetzt einfach festnageln mit
dachpappe nägel erstmal fixieren juni
und die werden und nachher keiner mit
einem kind wieder zu machen dass es
wieder wichtig jetzt mal ganz ehrlich du
hast doch schon mit klettverschlüssen
oder er hat doch schon mit
klettverschluss
er kommt noch immer ordentlich kommt der
nicht fragen wie hat er seine schuhe zu
gemacht du hast mir jedes mal fast auf
die finger ich weiß nicht getroffen denn
meine anatolischen hände wenn etwas
passiert richtig getroffen nein aber das
sieht
[Musik]
wir haben ja diese folien im juni schon
jetzt dran genagelt was wir jetzt auch
machen aber es hat damit zu tun weiß so
ziemlich lang ist
wir werden hier noch gewindestangen
reinmachen um das ding noch etwas zu
stabilisieren
weil da kommen wir ohne in den massen
von von von tonnen an erde hier rein was
manchmal tonnen passen ihr 1 4 tonnen
nicht auch oder alex gewonnen und das
wird wahrscheinlich alles nach außen
drücken um wissen wissen zu
stabilisieren machen wir jetzt
gewindestangen rein wenn euer hochbeet
luft solange ist dann brauchen diese
gewinne steigen nicht als stabilisation
reinmachen
wir machen das auch aus reiner
vorsichtsmaßnahme weil wir alles zu 100
prozent machen richtig das habe so
passiert damals das abstützen
was dann passiert dort was ich dann geht
es raus in den bauch
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt gerade die sockelleiste
ist ein doppelabschluss unten hin dass
genau das gleiche system wie bei unserer
treffer fast guckt euch mal das video an
außenfassade von der seele gibt es mal
bei youtube ein
und genau das system aber auch und das
sind hier kommen dann nachher dieses sei
die icsg einer das von prefa drauf diese
aluminium panels und ich glaub mich nun
ganz ganz sicher dass es so was noch nie
irgendwo auf der welt gegeben hat und
eine coole resteverwertung oder gummi ja
ok alles da wollen wir festigen
so jetzt warum alex die ersten panels
sind jetzt geht es noch relativ schnell
muss man sagen die werden hier einfach
eingesetzt die eingerastet und jetzt
muss mit dem schrauben hier fest von
alex gut gerade neben ihnen im wasser
sind und dann die zweite nationale ist
beim alex und bei mir geht's natürlich
ratzfatz und ich haben und bin da geht
es halt ein bisschen langsamer hab ich
recht und wer schützt auch schon eine
sein kann spart geschwitzt schon den
ganzen tag du wir machen das wir machen
ja wir schaffen da ja wir schaffen
lassen wo warst du denn ich habe ja aber
[Musik]
sollte sich einfach genau gleich wie
wollen so hausfassade ist ganz ganz
einfach zu machen
das habe ich jahrelang gemacht krieger
versagen dran geschraubt
das ist das nennt sich jetzt in
zwanziger ist ein kunststück das ist
seine zwischen verbindung ein wie der
hand abgeklemmt wie so eine zange
perfekt und jetzt ist nicht alles gold
so jetzt gibt's mal alles hin wir machen
heute jedoch komplett die ganze fassade
hier fertig und morgen was machen morgen
jungs genau dann haben die attika
sozusagen
wir haben aus holz die machen aus holz
und will morgen ist kein grillfest wir
kommen auch so was morgen kommt die
partie dahin und dann werden wir das
befüllen und ich glaube da ist auch die
die meiste aber ich hab ich recht alex
da brauchen wir richtig manpower das
heißt es gibt wahrscheinlich da alex wir
nicht machen müssen weil genau weißt du
natürlich nicht dabei ok also ich sage
das jetzt schauen wir dass noch fertig
und morgen geht es weiter
ja auch so machen
da brauchen sie nicht haben können
brauchen sie ja so 4342 haben jetzt
dieses hochbeet gebaut ja drei
zweieinhalb also haben dieses so werden
dieses hoch wie jetzt gebaut und jetzt
alex fängt das gärtnern richtig dass
also das bisschen gärtner
das besondere am hochbeet sind diese
drei bis fünf schichten und diese
schichten wenn man zeigen wir die
aufgebaut sind
hier habe ich am samstag ist ein schon
gemacht hat er aber keine kamera dabei
und konnte es nicht filmen aber dieses
stück habe ich noch frei gelassen
damit ihr euch ganz genau zeigen kann
wie sollen hochbeeten die schichten
aufgebaut sind
ich habe schon mehrere hochbeete gebaut
in meinem leben du auch alex genau und
bei mir schon so viel gewachsen das ist
in fast schon in mein schlafzimmer ist
und ihn ziemlich fast erwürgt hätte also
ich habe damit nicht ahnung davon nur du
hast problem wachsender oder einfach so
wieder hört nicht auf ihn
ganz kurz und zwar die schichten des
hofes in spa maßen aufgebaut
ganz unten machen wir jetzt eine
gesteinsschicht rheine stellt sich auch
die drainage schicht es dient dazu das
daher keine staunässe entsteht das heißt
durch die steine geht das wasser direkt
in den boden rein dann die zweite
schicht da machen wir jetzt fliesst rein
und zwar das vlies baureihen dass die
erde die nachher über den steinen nicht
nicht in steine reinrutscht und das
hochbeet sich denken tut dann kommt noch
die nächste schicht und die nächste
schicht ist ganz normale gesiebte mutter
erde die wir da rein machen dann machen
wir noch ein bisschen gras mit rein ein
paar schmidt abfälle
und die letzte schicht das ist so einen
anzug erde die machen wir ganz ganz oben
ganz dünn auf ganz dünnem drauf und da
ist ein substrat finden was einfach die
pflanzen zum wachstum anregt habe ich
recht sind alle schon weg
ok und jetzt machen wir ein wenig
zusammen die erste schicht rein und zwar
die steine und zwar das sind steine die
ich noch von den gabionen übrig hatte
dass ihr seht ich habe im hochbeet
lauter sein verwendet was bei mir noch
auf der baustelle herum gelegen ist und
diese steine werfen jetzt einfach rein
anschleppen steinen könnte man auch
gästen nehmen aber wir machen mit ich
steine weil ich habe einfach angst dass
nachher zu sehr ein sagt deswegen machen
wir gleich scheine im alex kann ich
jetzt mache mit dem juni nicht und wir
brauchen wir richtig muskeln alex kommen
wir zwar jetzt 12 30 sie ist dass alex
die drainage schickt machen wir ungefähr
20 zentimeter hoch zentimeter angaben
bitte das richtet sich immer nach eurem
nach europa
wahnsinn dafür braucht richtig viel
kraft
so jetzt haben die steine rein gemacht
das ist sozusagen die drainage schicht
hier kann es war danach richtig schön
ablaufen keine chance kein schimmel im
beet und was wir jetzt machen von der
teichfolie unter der deichkrone also ein
fließ drin jetzt mal aber das fließt
darüber dass die erde nicht darunter und
zwischen die steine rutscht so und hier
bei dem vlies könnte wirklich ein ganz
normales auch ein unkraut fließt nehmen
einfach einfließt reinmachen
das kriegt er überall im baumarkt und
jetzt haben wir das unkraut fuß rein
gemacht sodass fließe ist auch drin
unkraut fließt wasser fliesst auch immer
und jetzt mal ein bisschen erde und
vermischen ist noch mal zusätzlich ein
bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
rasenschnitt ein bisschen grünschnitt
und tut vielleicht auch noch ein
bisschen kaffee mit rein kaffeesatz
kamera ein machen
man kann auch noch obst und gemüse all
das obst und gemüse noch reinschmeißen
das machen wir jetzt wieder genau jetzt
machen wir erstmal ein bisschen von dem
hier
dazu braucht natürlich ein bisschen
kraft ein bisschen ding was alex will
ich natürlich haben was er natürlich
nichts hat mal gesagt haben 123
bist du vom alten rasen noch ein
perfektes stimmt und stimmt merkt er
dass das ist gut ich war
da kann man jetzt den ganzen normalen
natürlichen müll reinschmeißen sind nur
noch herumliegen hat ein bisschen gs
noch
[Musik]
sind es der sich ein regenwurm jetzt mal
ohne spaß ich wollte euch heute morgen
eigentlich noch in seiner fischerei
bedarf laden gehen und zwar regenwürmer
kaufen und direkt das mache ich auch
noch aber ist nämlich nicht mehr mit
kamera auf und zwar die riesen diese
regenwürmer die sind wird nicht gold
wert das heißt wirklich die regenwürmer
die tun denn den den boden auflockern
die die fressen was fressen kriegen wir
eigentlich machen humus so humus ansicht
der humus danny kent aus dem libanon
sondern der humus für die erde und
regenwürmer und nutzt hier sind ganz
ganz wichtig das heißt den regenwurm da
drin lassen und einfach die erde lockern
lassen der ist ganz ganz wichtig wo ist
der regenwurm
jetzt ist er weg aber da ist perfekt
romanistik papiers das wird nachher
alles alles zur erde borders stinkt das
ist nicht normal
so merkte dass schon das ist schon
richtig warm man merkt das zeug arbeitet
so auch stinkt das zeug warum sommer
hass und kuhstall daheim
das hochbeet erst einmal gepflanzt hat
es geht automatisch ein paar zentimeter
runter vielleicht so zwischen fünf und
zehn zentimeter lang gewässert haben uns
nachher nochmal besser aber da könnte
jedes jahr wissen auffüllen ich mache es
immer so ist es nicht auf ich bin
wirklich kaffeesatz das ganze jahr über
den kaffeesatz in meine in ein hochbeet
freilich sorgt für schädlinge übrigens
und richtig nährstoffreich
jetzt haben wir die geliebte mutter erde
drauf gemacht als dritte schicht
vielleicht war es auch nicht wird aber
aufgehört zu zählen ist
gesiebte ich habe sie ja auf jeden fall
ich habe sie geliebt und jetzt kommt
eigentlich die soll ich sagen die letzte
schicht und zwar die letzte schicht auf
einem hochbeet ist diese anzuchterde so
kann man hier die ist voll mit
nährstoffen
das ist sowas wie wie soll ich sagen wie
sagt man dazu doping für die pflanzen
jetzt noch jetzt wurde bei dir gesagt
okay auf jeden fall sehe das richtig und
es ist ohne job das ist rein biologisch
und deswegen wird es auch das risiko so
und jetzt machen wir mal ganz schön
drauf
[Musik]
so diese diese anzuchterde diese kräuter
er den kontrollen keine pflanzen tun
bekommen da ich in jedem baumarkt das
ist doch viel dritter kurs zwischen fünf
und acht euro
und das bekommt damit nicht überall und
das ist wie gesagt mir sehr sehr
nährstoffreicher boden oder erde und
dieser hier ist simone drauf rein
biologisch und biomärkte immer daran
wenn es bio ist es halt nicht wie du
morgens nicht zur arbeit kommt
somit dem hochbeet werden jetzt fertig
was wir jetzt noch machen uns war ich
habe dieses gardena bewässerungssystem
das heißt diese kopf schläuche wo ich
überall im garten gelegt habe dass ich
selber nicht mehr mit der hand bewässern
muss und jetzt sehen wir gerade diesen
topf schlauch und legen sie entlang des
ganzen hochbeete sda mit mir eigentlich
automatisch auch bewässern könnte ich ja
nix ganz wichtig bei dem gardena tropf
schlauch ist es das will ich kein knick
rein bekommt weil der arbeitet unter 3
bar druck und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig dass hier nichts dazwischenkommt
oder irgendwelche barrieren da sind so
jetzt haben wir auch den bewässerung
schlauch gelegt dass man überall löcher
drin den tropf schlauch und jetzt was
automatisch bewässert
das werde ich nachher noch fixieren aber
das machen wir erst später wenn wir noch
ein granulat drüber machen da sieht man
die schläuche nachher auch nicht mehr
der letzte schritt für uns handwerker
will jetzt sein
wir sind jetzt relativ blöd aus einfach
hier nichts zu haben und wir haben uns
überlegt noch mal ein bisschen von
unserer sibirische lärche
das ist für unsere hausfassade benutzt
haben und machen hier noch mal so was
wie eine attika tun die leicht an
winkeln das was nachher was drauf
tropfen ins beet rein läuft habe ich
recht alex sowas macht genau und wenn
wir die sibirische lärche angenommen
weil eine sibirische lärche ist sehr
sehr witterungsbeständig ist und langsam
gewachsen ist und zwar wo alex in in
sibirien genau richtig was wir nicht
können anatolische zwecke so ich glaube
wir nehmen mal als zweite schicht im hof
vergraben sollen wahrscheinlich ist also
auf jeden fall dass es nachher richtig
cool aussieht dass das gesamtbild
zwischen hausfassade und hochbeet und
passt machen wir dieses holz doch darum
sieht auch toll aus und richtig
natürlich mamas pest alex
ja ich habe nur eingefräst dass wir
nachher einfach die not hier in die
fassade einklinken können so ihr seht
auch die tropf des umfunktioniert und
hier kommt tropfenweise raus in der
stunde kommt ungefähr drei liter wasser
aus dem röhrchen raus das heißt ihm ist
wird nicht überlegen wie ihr euer
bewährten system einstellt weil drei
liter pro stunde ist nicht gerade wenig
aber sie ist perfekt
was jetzt noch passieren wird gebeten
wird sie mit einer zeit noch ein
bisschen setzen dann einfach noch ein
bisschen mit erde auffüllen oder mit
anzuchterde und irgendwann setzt sich
doch nicht mehr so jetzt immer jetzt
sind wir männer natürlich mit dem
hochbeet fertig richtig ja das habe ich
alles gut gemacht was wir jetzt noch
machen werden ist hier dass zum beispiel
einer farblosen lasso streichen damit
das holz einfach wie thomas geschützter
ist jetzt sind wir mit dem fertigen im
hochbeet und jetzt kommt endlich die
arbeiten haben nichts mehr zu tun
das ist ein landwirt in gottesberg jetzt
kommt teufels beitrag und zwar jetzt
kommt meine frau mit dem christian
zusammen sagt gottes werk gottes
beitragen so jetzt kommt meine frau im
christian zusammen es war christian ist
unser freunde der schule und zwar die
baumschule müller in maur lebensräume
müller genau
ja ich brauche zwei experten und zwar
genau denn die gummis am ende seiner
kompetenzen und zwar geht es jetzt um
pflanzen genauso auch genau das hab ich
gesagt genau herr aufnehmen so böse
sachen sagen so sally christian
staffelholz macht ihr fertiges
staffelholz nicht merken was ihr daraus
macht und wir gehen eher in die garage
jahren pause machen pause alles klar
viel spaß euch also los geht's
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir hier gerade ein
zerrbild denn unsere hochbeete da hinten
die werden ihr bepflanzten mit gemüse
und mit früchten mit kräutern und hier
wollten wir mal so was fürs auge haben
und haben jetzt eine bunte mischung und
du sagst das ist ganz logisch wenn man
dann erst mit den großen dingen anfängt
genau diesen pflanzen bilden das gerüst
und wenn du damit anfängst ist immer
leichter dann die kleinen dazu gehören
mit denen die lücken zu füllen
dann kann so auch gucken ist es stimmig
von der kooperation grundsätzlich die
höheren er nach hinten und nach vorne
abfallend weil das ja auch was die die
ansicht zahlt der du das bild dann
regelmäßig anschaust ok und muss man
hier irgendwie darauf achten welche
pflanzen sich womit verträgt oder hast
du jetzt hier schon so pflanzen
ausgesucht die wirklich miteinander
wachsen können also grundsätzlich ist es
nicht so dass sich pflanzen nicht
miteinander vertragen
sein wunsch ihr für das beet war dass
das mediterran sein soll zum einen
gleichen tarife anpassen gelaufen wir
hier auch die olive haben und das thema
sollte ja auch in die unterpflanzung der
olive ziehen
gleichzeitig war so ein bisserl der
gedanke ist lavendel und rosen muss und
deswegen habe ich die zistrosen
mitgebracht weil die richtige rose und
der lavendel die mögen beide komplett
unterschiedliche böden und um standorte
und deswegen passt es nicht wirklich
zusammen
ok perfekt da fühlen wir das jetzt noch
mit den kleinen pflanzen auf und dann
geht es gleich uns eine flanke
[Musik]
das ist lavendel einer meiner lieblings
pflanzen
ich würde sagen mir nutz und
zierpflanzen sieht schon aus und man
kann es auch nutzen
[Musik]
ich habe mir einen mauerpfeffer aus
mauer und das findet hier einen ganz
schönen flachen teppich ist aber nicht
essbar und es bildet einen schönen
teppich hier gerade rund um die uhr
liefe dann sieht man die erde darunter
nicht und macht es einfach immer schön
und farbig
also wenn man so kurz nach dem befüllen
gepflanzt dann muss man immer damit
rechnen dass ich auch dieses hochbeet
mit dieser art der befüllung noch ein
bisschen setzen also vom niveau her ging
ein tick höher weil so ein bisschen
runter geht also auf keinen fall zu tief
pflanzen ich habe ja sowieso eine andere
befüllung als es beim gemüse hochbeet
mal beim gemüse hochbeet da macht man so
dass man jedes jahr wieder neu gepflanzt
und da hat man ja diese sieben schichten
die daneben sich selbst sozusagen düngen
und hier haben wir jetzt nur um diese
stein schicht und dann machen wir was
haben dem rad macht steine dann den den
mutterboden und obendrauf noch mal hoch
aufgetürmte erde wie dem pflanzen guten
start ermöglicht und hier pflanzen wir
jetzt nur einmal und es bleibt dann
genau hier ist es ja als dauerhafter
bepflanzung angelegt im gegensatz zu den
gemüse hochbeeten die jedes jahr neu
doch ernst werden wo von daher ist man
froh wenn dass jedes jahr ein bisschen
sagt weil dann hat man die möglichkeit
da einfach mit niemand wieder eher
darauf zu sehen auf und hier wollen wir
das nicht also haben wir hier andere
schichten
was müssen wir jetzt beachten beim
einpflanzen also ich finde das sieht
schon ziemlich voll aus und es fühlt
sich ja dann auch noch mit der zeit für
mich wer jetzt wichtig zu wissen was
muss ich beim pflanzen beachten und
später dann eben die pflege fangen wir
mit dem bepflanzen oder genau also meine
pflanzen geht eben auch von gross nach
klaren dazu muss ich am leichtesten wir
fangen jetzt einfach mal hier mit der
miete an uns ein bisschen platz merken
uns sowas stand
legt man die pflanze so ein bisschen um
und dass man sie ohne schaden und ohne
schaden aus dem aus dem topf rausbekommt
teilweise ist dann außen so richtig
dicht hält den reist man ein bisschen
auf das kann mit einer harke sein oder
so mit der mit der hand einfach das so
lang kann genau dass die wurzeln nach
außen stehen und möglichst schnell hier
fest ok also es macht mal generell bei
allen pflanzen auf sehen wir später noch
mal einen kleinen die werden vermutlich
schon deutlich dichter das gewicht
werden da es ist noch wichtiger
und jetzt nicht so tief weil sich noch
ein bisschen salzig nicht zu tief
dann setzen wir jetzt einfach überall
erst mal die großen ein und danach die
kleine von groß noch klein
ok
und da kann man nix kaputt machen das
einfach so ein bisschen öffnen
und den bewässerungs schlauch einfach
einmal so einmal darum herum gelegt und
das reicht auch genau also wir haben wir
jetzt in den relativ engen abstammen so
dass das mit einfach gleichmäßig
bewässert wird und dass es völlig
ausreichend okay
eigentlich wollten tricks zeigen wie man
die pflanze besser rauskriegt dann dreht
man sich um und drückt drauf aber der
rosmarin ist so groß da musst du mir
helfen wenn die pflanze schon wie uns
ist die wurzel halt natürlich dagegen
dann hat man die einfachheit genau die
wurzeln wegnehmen
diesen krieg nicht mit der hand
auseinandernehmen und genau das einfach
so ein bisschen auf raum
[Musik]
wenn die plante man nicht raus geht
einfach auf dem topf außen hier drauf
drücken und umdrehen und dann rutscht
sie meist von allein ab
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir noch an ihm an ihn und
boden bei aktivator dazu und es sorgt
dafür dass die pflanzen schnell und gut
wachsen und gedeihen
als starthilfe das einfache zugang wird
dass wir ein richtig cooles plan für
pflanz fundament haben neben der erde
die er schon rein haben aktiver da ist
einfach für die mikroorganismen dass da
einfach das bodenleben entsprechend
angereichert wird und dass das alles
wegen tiefen staat und womit deckung
nicht mit drin also das ist eben immer
die frage womit deckt man ab damit das
erste unkraut nicht kommen da die option
etwas organisches wie wie die pinnwände
oder den rindenmulch oder heute habe ich
euch was mineralisches mitgebracht
einfach nur gebrochene lava die ich
finde zum mediterranen charakter
deutlich besser passt und damit denkmal
hauchdünn die fläche ab und dann hält
ist die feuchtigkeit ein bisschen und
verhinderten koda wuchs perfektes match
und den organischen dünger und das an
ihm aline das geben wir jetzt zum
schluss einfach auf die oberfläche durch
den regen sickert es dann immer in die
erde weiter runter und der unterschied
zwischen organischen und mineralischen
dünger ist dass es beim organischen kein
zuviel gibt der mineralische dünger der
entzieht ja meist auf dem boden die
feuchtigkeit und beim organischen kann
man echt nichts falsch machen einfach
schön bisschen verteilen also ist alles
gleichmäßig über der erde verteilt von
ihr stecke ich noch ab und dann ist
dieses hoch bild fertig jetzt haben wir
diese abschluss schicht sowie davon doch
auf der torte haben wir jetzt hier den
mineral dekor vulkane weinrot ich hab s
abgedrehten gekommene gebrochen müller
war eine gebrochene nase gebrochene lava
als deko schicht aber eben auch als
schutzschicht die hält nämlich die
feuchtigkeit im inneren und auch das
unkraut weg also drei nein zu sagen
[Musik]
wir setzen wir jetzt noch pflanzen um
den olivenbaum hat er auch so ein
schönes kräuterbeet hier unten
ich habe ein bisschen zitronenthymian da
vorne mauerpfeffer was hat es auch
rauschen auf blumen orangen blume
immergrüne pflanze die sich auch im
mediterranen pudelwohl fühlt und die
während der blütezeit ganz intensiv nach
zitrus duftet
[Musik]
hier vorne rücken auch zur kante kippen
dann wächst dann nämlich schön und
schnell drüber
[Musik]
so haben es fast geschafft was fehlt
noch das anwesen aber wir hoffen dass
die wolken ziehen schon ziemlich genau
hoffentlich
also ich finde sie jetzt schon richtig
schön was glaube ich mich auch meine
zuschauer richtig interessiert ist wie
muss ich das jetzt pflegen also gibt es
pflanzen die irgendwie schneiden muss
zurückschneiden im herbst oder im
frühjahr also die ganzen e mail grünen
pflanzen musst du nicht zurückschneiden
die kannst du jederzeit ein bisschen
schneiden aber die viren werden in der
regel nicht geschnitten okay aber so
sachen wie man da drin haben silber
strauch die blume lavendel die werden
geschnitten
es war es sei der richtige zeitpunkt das
zeitige frühjahr wo es dir vorstellen
wenn du vor dem winter her geht und
schneidest ist es so ist immer eine
schnittfläche da die gleichzeitig eine
eingriffsmöglichkeit für den pfosten in
die pflanze ist okay dadurch können dass
sein dass die karte die mediterran zu
weit zurück frieren und deswegen vor dem
winter so gut wie nicht schneiden nur
ein bisschen ordnung machen das
wegschneiden was sie stört und der
eigentliche rückschnitt der erfolg dann
rund um die forsythien blüte
das ist ende februar anfang märz das ist
der richtige zeitpunkt und wenn du
willst können wir das gerne im nächsten
jahr auf zusammen machen das machen das
heißt dieses jahr muss ich nichts mehr
tun außer mich an den blüten und an der
grünen wiese hier um allem erfreuen
genießen und genießen und jetzt zeige
ich euch im anschluss einfach noch ein
paar pflanzen und deren merkmale
vielleicht interessiert
[Musik]
die bad blue mit i zeigt lange nichts
von ihrer schönheit und blüht erst in
der zweiten jahreshälfte
also dann im herbst wenn man auch noch
viel im garten ist und dann blüht sie
für etwa sechs bis acht wochen
die blütenfarbe ist blau und die pflanze
wird etwa 60 cm groß das hier ist
netzwerk form vom heiligen bambus hat
mit dem eigentlichen bambus nichts zu
tun
er ist immergrün und hatten den schönen
lauf austrieb und im herbst verfärben
sich die blätter und macht hier einfach
immer das ganze jahr ein schönes
farbspiel die reben blüte ist so ein
bisschen ausgefallener sehr dunkle rote
blätter mit einer leuchtend violette
blattunterseite sie ist immergrün
wichtig ist dass sie keinen lassen fuß
hat es darf sich natürlich auch keine
staunässe bildet damit dem winter eben
auch nicht friert ich habe mir den
rosmarin und da gibt es zwei arten
einmal die aufrecht wachsende und die
überhängende pflanze die aufrecht
wachsende pflanze habe ich vorne im
gemüsebeet und hier haben wir jetzt die
überhängende pflanze im hochbeet und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier die
überhängende gewählt weil sie die kante
vom hoch bildschirm kaschiert also den
übergang zum olivenbaum
und weil ich sie eben auch beim kochen
und grillen verwenden kann und dann habe
ich hier eben auch ausreichend viele
rosmarin
ich habe mir noch eine ausgefallene
blume dass es die säcke blume die sorte
heißt emily brown und sie hat ein
kleines gesamtes laub und ist immergrün
und hat richtig schöne blaue blüten
diese pflanze ist silber winde
sie heißt so wegen dem silbergrauen
blatt also das ist was die farbe wie
beim oliv baum
sie ist ein dauerblüher und blüht im
ganzen sommer durch bis hin zum august
der ziersalbei gefällt mir hier fast
schon am besten weil er einfach eine
richtig schöne farbe mit rein bringt es
ist eine sehr dankbare pflanze nach der
ersten blüte kann man sie komplett
herunter schreiben also wenn sie ein
bisschen braun wird und dann blüht sie
wenn man glück hat auch wirklich noch
ein zweites oder drittes mal im jahr
ich habe mir den zeh salbei die pflanze
gefällt mir fast am besten hier hochbeet
es ist eine sehr dankbare pflanze und
jetzt blüht sie ja gerade sehr schön
bald werden die blüten dann braun und
dann kann man sie wirklich einmal
komplett herunter schneiden und mit viel
glück blüht sie dann noch ein zweites
oder sogar noch ein drittes mal im jahr
[Musik]
das schafft dann bin ich ging alles
darauf hin dass darüber ja stets so
schwer
schaffe ich das ich bin sehr schlecht im
schmeißen was wir dagegen kommt ist das
schlimm
das schaff ich nicht wo mein gott
natürlich vermissen ich dachte keiner
show mein gott jetzt geschafft sagt
nachbar